I'm so happy!
Hinode? Hinode!
Muge!
-Hinode! No! Not Hinode!
-Hey! Behave!
Stop that!
I have to go back to being a human!
What?
Hey! You have to
take better care of your life!
It belongs to me now!
Hey, hey! Come back here!
What's going on?
Hinode shouldn't be here!
He has to go back!
He said he wants to study pottery.
He wants to be like his grandpa!
Hinode! Over here!
Muge!
Hinode!
Excuse me, is that going up?
What? Oh, yes.
Can I hitch a ride?
Oh, sure thing!
Is that going up?
All clear!
-Is that going up?
-Go!
Hinode!
Hinode! No!
Go back!
-Seriously?
-What?
Muge!
Hinode!
You can do it, Hinode!
Let's go home, Muge.
I...
Hinode, I--
I'm sorry.
Why are you apologizing?
I'm not the sharpest tool in the shed.
I only realize who's been supporting me
behind my back when they're gone.
I've always been like this.
I...
I finally realized the truth
when I learned you were actually Taro.
You cheer me up at school.
It was always you.
Wait, really? Do you mean that, Hinode?
And that's why I have to change! I--
You should stay the way you are.
Mask Seller!
I'll take your lifespan too...
-as compensation.
-Let go of him!